one notion that i have is that and i'm
and i'm gonna say it and then i'm gonna
explain it
is that people don't care i mean
seriously we we produce products we're
passionate we think this feature is
amazing
you have to try it this product is is
life-changing
and then you you go to market with it
and you find that well you know
people are not you know they're not
stopping their life
for you welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by eric singh
vp of marketing at windward eureka is a
seasoned executive with a demonstrated
history of developing
and growing businesses in the high-tech
industry for both b2b
and b2c products currently she is vp of
marketing at windward
the leading maritime ai company prior
experiences include senior director at
microsoft
vp marketing adhere technologies
mobility division and
cmo at mobley media
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great how are you
good you know it was hard to make this
happen lots of technical difficulties
but we did and it's going to be
fantastic for these next 20 minutes
and you have a very unusual background
from electrical engineering bachelors
from television university
entered l'oreal as a full-time
algorithms developer
transitioning to marketing management
and now
continuing to as a as a marketing
executive across
amazing companies like mobley here
technologies now windward ai
doing marketing for deep tech companies
and i'm fascinated by this
but this weird transition that i don't
often see so it take me back to
you as an engineer by trade and your
perception
of of transitioning to marketing so
uh to me it makes sense right uh it all
makes sense
uh i i've always been a tech geek i
guess
um so that's where i found myself in
electrical engineering and i worked
uh developing algorithms in several in
different companies from you know from
enterprise to startups
uh you know 10 people in some shabby
room
working day night and when i finished my
mba
i thought it made sense to i think
practice or study marketing uh probably
one of the best schools for marketing
uh which is l'oreal so i started there
as an intern
came in for three months and found
myself there
uh completely enchanted by by mascaras
and colors and fashion
like a total geek would and stayed there
for a few years a few good years
but my drive for technology my passion
for that has always existed so i
it got me back to microsoft where i was
leading the business unit of windows and
devices
kind of combining both consumer and b2b
um capabilities in the tech space
um and from there on it it just
continued with technology which is
really where i
i was always supposed to be probably
now when you transition from algorithms
developer to marketing
very very different what was that
actually like you know even socially or
or you know
professionally all of a sudden your
day-to-day looks completely different
right
completely different um
180 degree shift but i think
that both um both engineers
and marketing are creativity based on
creativity it's a different kind of
creativity
obviously and there you use different
skill sets
but at the end of the day you're
creating something
and i just think that a piece of what i
was doing as an engineer was missing for
me i wanted to
get a the bigger picture i wanted to
understand
how this influences the market
and and the different uh um use cases
and impacts so it wasn't just about
developing the code and and doing the
the r d stuff
and and i found marketing just
fascinating um and combining the skills
and the understanding of technology i
think that
gives me a big advantage when i come
into companies
uh my ability to understand thoroughly
also the the product but also where the
engineers are coming from and kind of
understand and connect the dots
you know you read you're taking me
exactly where i wanted to end up which
is this idea of marketing
for deep tech companies usually you know
i think that
people think different differently about
different professions and
and one of the the things that people
are aware of is this dissonance between
you know marketing and storytelling
versus developing the algorithms and
they seem like two distinct things
but in order to make a company
successful they actually have to work
very much together
right and so tell me a little bit about
why
why is it helpful to you to understand
the engineering and the algorithms
while doing a marketing job so obviously
everything's connected and marketing is
not a standalone
um part of the company
for marketing to work at its best there
needs to be
collaboration between products and and
the marketing team and the sales team
everybody really needs to work together
and from my experience
the best results are always when there's
synergy
between the different departments the r
d
people it's it's important for both for
two things one
internally so employer branding
obviously if you have
people on board with you and they
understand and they get what you do
and they have a feeling of
accomplishment so you know that they're
working hard and then there's someone
that takes the ball from them and and
brings it out to the world so my job as
a marketer is really to tell
people uh to tell the ecosystem about
the great job
that these people these engineers are
doing and i'm very proud to do it and in
order to do it i think at the best it's
it's about personal connection it's
about knowing the people
knowing what they're doing understanding
um the
the science or the brains behind the
product
um it it enables me to better market it
better explain it and also to understand
the challenges
that may be when using the product
right and so as you're then leading
teams
of marketing so you're not actually
doing a lot of marketing yourself you're
vice president of marketing you're
actually on you're you're strategically
thinking
through how to for example win word ai
maritime deep technology artificial
intelligence
how do you i'm assuming that not
everybody on your marketing team truly
understands the algorithms
naturally because it's a different
profession right well yes i don't you
know it really depends and you don't
really need to understand to the full
length of the algorithm
um i have to say that everyone on my
team
and is amazingly uh dedicated and
understands the product
sometimes are are just excited about
sitting with with the engineers or the
product people
um and obviously to to your comment
before i don't do everything on my own i
have an amazing team and
and one of the things that i find uh
most important
is building a strong marketing team and
the people that are on the team
are people that i think are probably the
best marketers
out there um and it's a lot of teamwork
so yes some people are more uh uh
involved or in understanding the product
some
some less but it it's it's across the
team so
from product marketing to content to
the creative designer everybody needs to
understand what the product
does in order to get a clear message
because marketing is all about
getting the message out so it could be
through a visual or it could be through
text but eventually you really need to
have a deep understanding
of what you're selling here what you're
marketing
right so i think that you know some
engineers that look at marketing and
think okay they think billboards
facebook advertisements
share with me you know what excites you
about marketing you know
also like through the eyes of an
engineer so how does mark how do you
actually think strategically through
marketing for a deep tech company like
marriage like a windward ai
right so definitely ai is deep tech
and and the product um is
is on the one hand very uh uh i would
say complex it
it has a lot of of you know uh machine
learning and
and ai models so it's it's very
high tech but on the other hand the
product is very simple
so you have a very simple ui ux so it's
very clear you can generate
reports and i think that a lot of
the collaboration between marketing and
product is how to simplify
uh the understanding of the product the
value of the product
because we're not selling features we're
not selling a product we're selling a
solution
and marketing is creating that
experience and and
to me that's that's the most exciting
part of it um
understanding what makes people tick
what makes them choose your product over
others
um and and you know i've had consumer uh
experience and i've had
a b2b and b to g experience
but at the end of the day it's all about
people
um it's it's really everyone is a
consumer
so whether you're a cfo or cto or an
analyst or
just you know
jennifer whatever from from la you're a
consumer
and and i'm trying to take you through a
journey
to understand the value and the the
added value that i bring to your life
with that product within the
organization
what what how does that work so i
understand the whole you know
outbound where we're taking the
organization and we're bringing it to
the real world and taking new people on
a journey
what is the journey within the
organization and what part do you play
as a vp of marketing within the
trajectory of the growth of the startup
so so i think it's it's it varies
from from company company obviously but
there are some
basic uh things that are are really uh
same for every every tech company i
would say
um one is is connecting
the people to the marketing efforts um
it's not standalone um you know you want
to have
the people at home believing in what you
do and
through transparency and communication
we share a lot of what we do so we don't
do things
like silos and if we have a conference
or a webinar
everybody's involved we get the sales
people on board and the
business operations involved and
obviously the product team is involved
and we try to get
everyone on board and and through i
think
having that and having the feeling that
you're part of it
even if you know everyone has a
different job or everyone has a
different part
in making this startup great um
and if we all did the same job we
wouldn't you know we wouldn't grow
so the idea is that everybody does what
they're really good at
but everyone has a place to contribute
and
to give ideas and you know i'm always
open and i think that that's the one
thing that i say to anyone who's new to
the company you have
any crazy idea small or big you know
come and tell me i'm always interested
in hearing and i think that some of the
greatest ideas we get from people that
you
would never think are marketers or are
not
by profession um but once again it's
people and people use
products and and eventually we're all
well all consumers of
this product 100 now
as you're spending six years in r d
and then marketing you know i'm guessing
many years
i'm guessing that you also came into
this to the marketing world with some
preconceived notions and some
expectations
what what debunked them what what are
some non-trivial things that you've
learned
across your career now that you say well
perhaps a lot of my engineering friends
don't really understand
this part of this part which i happen to
understand because i've been there for
so long now
so i think that the one thing that the
the one notion that i have
is that and i'm going to say it and then
i'm going to explain it
is that people don't care i mean
seriously we produce products we're
passionate we think this feature is
amazing
you have to try it this product is is
life-changing
and then you you go to market with it
and you find that well you know
people are not you know they're not
stopping their life
for you um and and i think that
it's always interesting to see how
people react so you really need to find
that
that thing that makes them want to do
the effort because if it requires effort
for them you know even just
changing i don't know the color of
the the screen or whatever you know
people won't won't bother
so that's a general notion that when you
go into marketing you think oh
all i need to do is great marketing and
everybody's gonna get it right
and then you go to market and you
understand and it's not specific to any
product it
it was in in l'oreal as a consumer
product and it's at microsoft and it was
you know
uh at windward or whatever you really
need
to be very very accurate and precise
in finding what makes that specific
persona
want to make a change um and and
sometimes it could be
you know as silly as he wants to look
good for his boss
so if you have the right report that
makes him look really smart
without putting too much effort then
you've got him and he's going to buy the
product
so i think that being in love with the
products
is something that is very um i think
typical as an engineer because you say
well wow i did this
super smart thing
but that's not good enough that's not
good enough and and as a marketer you
understand
that and our job is really to find
the way to make people care
and to create that emotional connection
to your brand
into your product and so what what are
the implications of this internally
because that puts a lot of pressure on
marketing
right if an engineering team develops a
great feature
if it doesn't work out in the market
then i guess marketing didn't do a good
enough job right um
well it also first of all it always
depends on on a good
product right and then it depends on on
market fit
uh right obviously everyone in
in the chain is responsible for the
success
and you don't really know what the
secret sauce of a successful
you know company is sometimes it you
know
some some companies you say i don't get
it how they're
you know how they're doing so well and
others you say i don't get it
how how isn't that you know they're not
a 10 billion dollar company
um so it really differs but i think
everyone is responsible so
the the there's a lot of pressure
obviously on the r
d and product teams and our job is to
make everybody aware of the great things
that we do
so there's a lot of pressure on
marketing obviously um
and on the sales team and well you know
on everyone
from from finance to to
to keeping the the office uh
fun and tidy yes to hr to everyone so
it's a great effort one of the things
that i love doing with this show
is you know ask questions about my own
journey that i'm going to be tackling
with and i have
a unique opportunity to speak to amazing
people like you that have so much
experience
and so i'm going to pick your brain a
little bit i imagine you know starting a
company and you know i'm in r d
and i think that i can you know build a
product nice and then i'm really scared
about
you know what am i going to do with
marketing and when do i hire marketing
and
how do i even prioritize and think
through it what advice would you give me
as a young entrepreneur as i start my
journey
how should i as a non-marketing guy very
technical how
should i go about thinking strategically
about building my own marketing
operations for whatever startup i happen
to build
so first of all i think that this is
something that has improved in in the
past uh
in the past few years um definitely in
the
in the tech scene in israel that i've
seen
marketing needs to be on board
as soon as possible so from day one i
would say
because building a product that
nobody cares or nobody needs
is a waste of time and efforts and you
know i've seen some
some amazing uh r and d work
with with entrepreneurs that you know i
look at the product and say well okay
it's super smart
i know you put a lot of effort but you
know who's who's gonna pay for this
you know um so i think that getting
marketing on board
just to understand product market fit um
understand the messaging
understand the personas that you're
planning to sell
product to um can save a lot of time and
effort
uh in the beginning of any of any
development of product
so i would say as soon as possible right
now if i were to go back you know to
your time at microsoft would you imagine
years down the line you'd be where you
are today
in terms of either professionally you
know in marketing or working with with a
startup and not with a big corporation
um i think it made a lot of sense for me
um to be at microsoft
it's a company i love uh till this day
um and and i i have nothing but great
words to say about it um but it was
pretty obvious that i would
look for for a company that is
more in the building i love building
things
i think that's where my creative juices
uh
are at their best um so it was pretty
obvious and
and this is a journey you know i'm
having a lot of fun i'm i'm learning new
technologies meeting a lot of
interesting people
new uh spaces um verticals
and yeah and it's just it's just fun
technology is
is amazing in that sense that everything
and anything can be new but
everything that you learn and any place
that you go to
is another building block in your
journey and
and it's just amazing okay this was
wonderful thank you for taking the time
to share your journey with me i have a
few questions not about marketing not
about
when were they ai or microsoft but about
irit and so i'm gonna take you back to
middle school
oh wow yeah what fascinated you as a kid
what what is a subject in school perhaps
that you were really fascinated
i'm gonna sound like a geek but math
it was it was everything to me i mean i
did uh
uh extra extra curriculum work on in
math
uh i just anything and everything to do
with math
it's it's very embarrassing but it's
true
very very cool and who would be a role
model of yours or somebody that inspired
you
real or fake person over these years
well i undoubtedly um
my mom is the most inspiring person for
me
um ever since i was a kid she's
you know she was a she's a
med school professor she always had a
great career always had time for for
family
and and really probably my best friend
my kids are inspiring to me they teach
me you know new things every day
teach me things about myself and and i
think make me a better person
which is what i try to do on a daily
basis i love it and what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um oh wow uh integrity
um accuracy
and well this isn't a word but getting
things done
consider it done i'm that kind of person
so
amazing this was amazing
thank you thank you for doing your time
i learned so much really thank you and
stay safe and stay healthy and i can't
wait to show this to the world thank you
thank you
you